I love making movies motion pictures has
been in existence for more than 100
years filmmaking hasn't changed for the
dimensional mindset place the camera in
the scene and pristine record hasn't
changed filmmaking is still affronted
experience and creating the film has the
possibility to follow the same direction
of the content creation we still stand
in front of a flat image watching the
feature there's nothing wrong with it I
love watching movies and going to the
theaters the experience will be so
emotional experiences the art and craft
of motion experiences within the frame
can be so strong to drive a strongly
emotional the question we're asking is
how the experience of motion pictures
can exist beyond the flat screen how can
we start creating content through the
generation of content experiences
traditionally when we imagine a scene we
look at the frame and the composition we
have to think about how we create depth
and parallax using foreground background
elements as the camera moves with the
technology today and devices of VR
glasses air glasses smart devices
allowing three-dimensional and full
navigation in space we have the
possibility to enable audience to
experience content for multiple
perspectives what we have to think about
is how we take this technology or the
capabilities enabling the experience to
move farther away inside the sea now
we're not talking about video games or
computer-generated actors which looks
tremendously realistic we're talking
about real actors and real performance
performing on stage we have to start
thinking how we capture the actors and
how we capture the real sea in order to
immerse inside now we're familiar with a
360-degree video
where you place the camera inside the
scene and you can create this beautiful
panoramic image all around you but from
the same aspect filmmaking is still
fronting in order to immerse food inside
the scene we will need to capture the
lights from all the possible directions
we'll have to surround the scene with an
enormous amounts of sensors with all
possible capabilities to capture the
light and enable us to emerge inside
afterwards again now in this setup
there's no more foreground or background
or a camera place in space but hundreds
of sensors capturing the light and
captured emotion from all the possible
directions with the new technology
advancements we can start looking at 3d
photography capturing the light from
multiple perspectives enable us to
reconstruct the subject this is like
photography in 3d space
now with this technology advancements we
can record video not just as a flat
image but as a volume this is what we
call volumetric video and is the
capability to record every action on the
scene as a full three-dimensional volume
now what is a voxer a voxel is like a
three-dimensional pixel but instead of
being a flat image square staying light
and color is like a 3-dimensional cube
in space with X Y & Z position this
enables to create a full capture of the
scene from any perspective now this
renders a fully light immersive scene
from multiple perspective this
capability requires an insane amount of
information to be processed we will help
to capture the light for numbers amount
of cameras to create this information
now in order to do such a thing we will
need a setup that will host a numerous
amount of cameras installed in a stage
and a stage big enough in order to fit a
full cinematic experience
now that sounds like a crazy idea but
that's exactly what we did for the last
three years we have been building a huge
volumetric camera chamber it's 10,000
square feet of a stage in everything to
capture the action from any location we
have deployed hundreds of cameras
singing the tremendous amount of
information to a huge data center
powered by Intel supercomputers the
ability to have this 10 servers field
enable us to fit any kind of action any
kind of performance it is the size of an
average of a Broadway stage we call it
intersted years and is the largest
volumetric stage in the world with the
objective of enabling and exploring the
next generation or the tremors of media
filmmaking now to test this ideas we
were thinking about what we can do as
the first scene to try it out so we
choose the Western scene were both
horses set designers dirt everything
needed to create a full scene of a
Western but this time there was no
camera inside there was nothing really
moving beside the old cameras incidents
in the oxide the challenge of the actors
was tremendous they have to perform a
flawless action visible from all the
directions there is no possibility to
hide a punch or not show the action
everything is captured and everything is
seen the output of the capture or our
first really Apter is our first capture
open our lives for the amazing
capabilities it was like a full 3d
scheme of the entire scene we were able
to move around and travel in the space
think about this is nothing more about
perceiving the light emitted from a
screen but now traveling inside the
light traveling inside the sea this
obviously opens possibilities for an
enormous amount of storytelling and
methodologies of
creation this is the possibilities of
your personal narrative the possibility
of creating your own story inside or
maybe following other stories let's take
a look at one of the last renders and
see what we're seeing here it's for
volumetric video and there's no physical
camera in the scene we have the full
control of space and time
[Music]
now again no physical camera was here
everything was captured surrounding now
this is very nice but what if you wanted
to see the scene maybe from the eyes of
the horse well we can do that as well so
what you're seeing right now is the same
action but this time we're watching it
exactly from the eyes of the horse
the possibilities are were unlimited so
this is all great for creators and
storytellers it really opens a huge
canvas for different type of
storytelling and moviemaking but what
about the audience how the audience can
experience this differently in order to
clip our explorations we partner with
Paramount Pictures in order to explore
immersive media in a Hollywood movie
production together with the director
under laser we reimagine the iconic
movie of the 1978 Greece some of you
know it some of you know 40 years old
movie amazing experience and our goal
was really to look how we can take this
in you know iconic action and dance and
bring it deeper into the experience
bringing deeper to the audience imagine
that you can not just watch the movie
but get inside it and dance with the
actors and dance with the performance
now we're breaking really the
traditional to these mindset of thinking
and bringing a much richer possibility
for moviemaking and content creation but
why to watch it on the screen let's try
to bring these actors here on the stage
so they're not going to really come I'm
going to use an - sorry I'm going to use
an iPad in order to bring in a rented
reality now obviously these devices has
their own limitations in terms of the
data computing process so we have to
reduce the amount of resolution so what
I'm doing now I'm placing here a marker
so I be able to position exactly where I
want everyone to appear okay I think we
have them here john travolta or a
version of him let's take a look
[Music]
hey guys check this out
[Music]
so as you can see we can watch an
experience content on the traditional
way or an immersive way really the
possibilities are open we're not trying
to change or replace movies we're
enhancing them the technologies enable
new possibilities to start thinking
beyond the flat screen where an
immersing and really exciting times in
filmmaking where the threshold of a new
area we're opening the gates for new
possibilities of immersive storytelling
an exploration and defining what
immersive media filmmaking means we're
really just at the beginning and we
invite you all to join us thank you
[Applause]
[Music]